[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
hey conan o'brien here this is my video
blog
here's what's going on in my world
i hate to start this video with some bad
news but i lost a really good friend
this week
i'm talking about the shamrock shake
i feel like every time i let you back in
my life you disappear for a whole year
again
so i made this video blog dedicated to
you
shamrock shake
[Music]
that took eight hours
i saw that movie john carter
i thought it was pretty cool but i guess
it's a huge flop
i think it's because the title of the
movie is john carter
it's kind of a boring title so i wanted
to help fix the title
in a new segment i'm calling
way better titles than john carter
way better titles than john carter
like for example this one would be much
better john carter and also space
monsters
star wars episode 7 the one with john
carter
and friday night lights but instead of
texas it's mars and there's this guy in
it and his name is john carter
those are all
way better titles than john carter way
better titles than john carter
speaking of movies i noticed lots of
cool kick-ass movies have been using the
same kind of big scary sounds in all
their movie trailers it sounds like this
i wish i could use that sound whenever
i'm talking so everything would sound
more dramatic
like a taco bell i'd say
can i get a chimichanga
beef
no sour cream please
because i'm lactose intolerant
you know there's a lot going on with the
president-elect elections right now so
here's a segment that has nothing to do
with that called animals with emotions
animals with emotions
this cat is a jets fan who's pissed
about the tim tebow trade
i like how my hair peeks out on the top
[Applause]
this dog just ate a weird brownie at a
fish concert
[Applause]
this hawk just saw the hulk hogan sex
tape
[Applause]
this pig also just saw the hulk hogan
sex tape and can't wait for the sequel
that was animals with emotions animals
with emotions all right that's what's
going on in my world right now hey conan
and i got you this latte oh thanks sandy
um did you get it the way i like it yeah
grande
extra foam
with soy milk
because
you're lactose intolerant
[Applause]